[Music]
good morning everybody it's seven
o'clock the prime minister is promising
to throw everything at the booster drive
with every adult in england able to book
a third jab by the end of january
that's booster jabs for 23 million
people a huge effort that will require
an army of volunteers and the real army
to help expand the capacity of the nhs
and get needles into arms we're going to
be speaking to the health secretary
sajid javid vray shortly along with
scotland's top health advisor and to
labor about why they want tougher travel
restrictions and the doctor said you're
hiv positive he was in hospital and he
said anti-ages come to call i felt like
i was the walking dead
world aids day going to be speaking to
one of the longest living people in the
uk diagnosed with hiv about the new sky
documentary which tells the story of
britain's 40-year battle with the virus
and
tougher penalties for child abuse is
tony's law named after a very brave
little boy tony hudgell there he is
bless his cotton socks has the
government's backing after a four year
campaign gonna be speaking to tony and
his mom and dad within the next hour
it's wednesday the 1st of december
don't cancel christmas parties the
message from the prime minister despite
advice from one of his most senior
health officials to cut out unnecessary
socialising
boosting the booster i'm live at a
vaccination center in surrey where the
government is throwing everything in its
booster campaign
also ahead a new report reveals hundreds
of thousands of potential cancer cases
could have been missed during the
pandemic
high school shooting a teenager is in
custody after three pupils were killed
and several injured in the u.s state of
michigan
i think this is every parent's worst
nightmare
the first accuser in the gillane maxwell
sex trafficking trial says she was
abused by jeffrey epstein when she was
14 with the british socialite in the
room
[Music]
morning the prime minister boris johnson
is promising that more than 23 million
people will be able to book a booster
jab by the end of january it's a massive
expansion of the vaccine program and the
government is appealing for thousands of
volunteers to help the nhs temporary
vaccine sites will be set up around the
country and around 400 military
personnel will assist the rollout but if
mr johnson had another message it was
that christmas is safe and there is
still time to party the health secretary
sanji javid is with us lots to get
through let's talk good morning to you
let's start first of all with um our
viewers
sense of exhaustion this morning that we
have to deal with another twist and turn
in this covid um challenge um how are
you coping with it all
well there's a there's a lot of work to
be done and i just have to start by
thanking all the people in the nhs
especially in social care for
you know think of the the two years that
they've had the most challenging time i
think they'd say in living memory for
anyone uh working in in in care and
health and now you know this variant
comes along and it's uh
you know we've we have to still ask more
of them i know they're up to it but it's
a big ask and i just want to stand by
start by thanking them and
with this variant we
we are you know we we're trying to learn
and assess more about it and in the
meantime in the next few weeks we want
to build our defenses and our best form
of defense still remains our vaccines
it's possible of course it's possible
that it might be less effective we just
don't know for sure yet but it's also
very likely that they'll remain
effective against serious disease and
that's why we made the announcement
around the booster program yesterday
i asked the jcvi that's our group of
independent advisors on vaccines whether
it would now make sense in life this
variant to really expand the program
it's already really successful but to
really properly expand it and they came
back and said we should do just that by
dosing
so
halving the dosing interval and also by
expanding it to all adults and it's a
real national mission i would say for
all of us we've all got a role to play
on this and and if any of your viewers
if they if they get the call from the
nhs then please do i would just say to
them please do you know step up roll up
your sleeves and protect yourselves
23 million booster vaccines to be slated
by the end of january though that's a
tough ask isn't it that's what half a
million a day
it's it's a huge ask and uh
it's something i i do believe that the
all the people working in the nhs all
the volunteers they are up to it but it
is it of course is a huge ask that's why
i call it a national mission this has
become from a health point of view uh
the most important thing that we can do
to protect ourselves to protect the
progress uh that we've made but i know
that the nhs uh are up to it in the last
week you know before sort of omicron
was a thing we i think delivered about
2.4 million vaccinations across the uk
and that's obviously that's that's huge
we need to increase that by around a
million uh a week but i i think it can
be done to to give everyone an offer by
january but it's really important that
people take up that offer because that's
what's going to protect us that's
counter through lots to talk about the
pm says the new rules will be assessed
after three weeks what criteria what do
you use
the
the
key thing will be the assessment of our
scientists uh of the variant now what we
need to determine
is it you're any more dangerous than the
delta variant and as i say we don't know
the answers to that we've seen in the
last few days a number of scientists
whether from here from south africa i
spoke to my counterpart in south africa
yesterday and let me also just say i
think the way south africa has behaved
is is exemplary in in being open and
transparent about what it discovered but
in in in talking to other scientists we
don't know enough about it yet but that
will be the key thing is to determine uh
if it is any more dangerous than the
current dominant variant the delta
variance three weeks is an arbitrary
figure isn't it really because it could
take longer than that for us to know
whether people have got it and then find
themselves in hospital we won't know
within three weeks just the challenge
that we're facing with this well um i
wouldn't call it an arbitrary figure i
think where you might be a bit right is
that
you know it might it yeah only a bit is
that it it might take a bit longer than
three weeks it might be a bit sooner
than three weeks of december as opposed
to 25th you know but see where i'm going
with that yeah no of course and that's
why we we we're confident that actually
maybe within two weeks that we can know
a lot more about this we might not even
need to wait three weeks but the three
weeks was i think a a sort of a a
sensible date to set for a review
because
now that we have live samples of the of
the virus they've gone to our labs in
important down our scientists and the
best scientists in the world are working
through it we're working with our g7
colleagues i held a meeting with g7
health ministers on monday as well to
discuss this and so we're working
internationally we're working at pace at
home and i think in a couple of weeks we
will know a lot more about this variant
between now and then the prime minister
said we should be attending christmas
parties
the chief adviser saying we shouldn't
where are you
well i think people should continue to
behave in the way that they were
planning to behave over over christmas i
don't think there's any need uh to
change those plans the only changes that
have been made in the last few days are
the ones that everyone now i think knows
about about it might affect your
international travel plan so if someone
had plans to travel over christmas
then there could be an impact there of
course uh there's the need to
self-isolate if you come into contact
with someone uh with uh omicron yeah are
you worried about the pandemic
no no i'm not um the case numbers are
well at this point in time the case
numbers are are very low i think
throughout the uk we've got 22 confirmed
case at the moment and that will go up
it will certainly uh go up but the
numbers are low i hope it sort of stays
that way so i i'm not worried about the
sort of pandemic type situation but
we've always also said that even before
we knew about the variant you know our
sort of plan a we've always been clear
that
as you get into
deeper winter the colder darker days the
virus likes that not just this virus the
flu virus they like that and so you know
as we do that then your people should
just be you're careful to to try and
think can they ventilate a room and just
follow the current guidance let's crack
on um should people take a test uh cover
test before they go to a christmas party
i would i would it's not a formal
recommendation the guidance but if i was
going to a party with lots of people and
things i would but i would have done
that by the way even before we knew
about this variant again the reason i
would have done that is because it's
getting colder it's getting darker we're
spending more time indoors probably more
people indoors than before just because
of the colder darker days so are
sensible precautions that everyone can
take you're talking about overseas
travel labor saying that there should be
pre-departure tests from the country
that you are in before you come into the
uk why don't we do that we used to do it
we did used to do it and we got rid of
it because we didn't think we needed it
anymore when the variant came along and
with what little we do know about it we
had to
it was right to take some
measures around travel and the most
important one we actually took is the
red listing so you know the moment i
learned about this virus and and the
potential threat of it within hours we
redlisted six countries in southern
africa we've added four more we're the
first in the world to do that and then
also we've put in this measure around if
you come in from anywhere in the world
that you will have to take a pcr test by
day two and uh only can already be only
leave isolation if you get a negative
test is it under review the two the
pre-departure testing we keep all these
rules under review i don't anticipate
any change from what we've announced
just in the last few days but of course
we always keep it in review should the
situation change then we would have to
look at that again but i don't really
anticipate any change for now the world
health organization yesterday said over
60 shouldn't travel overseas what do you
think
look the the the world health
organization is taking this very
seriously which is is
really
important and uh we are working uh with
them uh it's understandable they're
concerned about them no i i would just
say
again we just stick to what we already
know right even there's a lot we don't
know about the very what
what we know is that the older you are
the more
vulnerable you are to this virus
and there are ways to sensibly protect
yourself
so if you ask if it was my mother you
know um i would say to her you know
she's got her booster shot so that's
great if she really wanted to travel you
wear a mask on the plane and things like
that but i don't think you she should be
worried about traveling so that would be
my advice um you talked about south
african scientists and uh how much
praise they needed again talking about
the world health organization yesterday
they said um that because of what we did
and the fact that we put them and the
other countries on the red list that
disincentivizes countries to report and
share epidemiological and sequencing
data do you agree
well i think i think they there's a
there's a point about
making sure that those countries that
come forward and share the information
like south africa did like the uk did
when we had the alpha variant you'll
remember that and uh and we were very
open with the rest of the world just in
the same way south africa is and that's
the right thing to do it's a much poorer
country than us and they rely much more
on tourism and they're being penalized
i wouldn't say they're being penalized i
i agree with everything else you just
said about south africa but it is really
important that the rich countries that
they recognize that south africa has
come forward done the right thing and
offers it whatever support it needs so
on the the call that i organized with g7
health ministers on monday we talked
about this we we it was in our final
statement about praising south africa
and offering even more support than
otherwise and yesterday is one of the
reasons i had a call with the south
african health minister to offer our
support so you don't agree with the
world health organizations that it
disincentivizes countries
you put them on the red list no i think
it's it's important that countries come
forward but there are other ways to
support them okay can we talk about nhs
waiting times please if we may uh
national audit office report uh
estimating that if 50
of those that have missed their
referrals during the pandemic come
forward then the waiting list would
reach 12 million by march 2025.
in fact i i think i've previously been
on your program and said it could reach
13 million for precisely the same reason
and uh and by the way i do want people
this fact is in the money that you've
already that you hope to raise as well
though doesn't it from the national
insurance contributions the rise um
well i
i don't know if it does apparently but
but yeah i don't know and even if it did
i don't think they would at this point
know about all the plans that we've got
to to you know get through the waiting
list much faster than otherwise because
of all the new funding that's coming but
that said
the the waiting list
will rise before it falls it'll rise for
two reasons first is that a lot of
people that didn't come forward are
coming forward and again i want them to
come forward i hope it's more than 50
percent even that's more work for the
nhs i don't want anyone to think that
they have to stay away from the nhs and
secondly we've got a lot of the demand
in any case even before the delay demand
there's there's there's all those sort
of usual demand that would be there now
that said the work that we're doing on
especially on elective procedures and
diagnostics with the new community
diagnostic centers with their surgical
hubs yeah this is all going to make a
big difference is also better by this
time next year
it i think we'll be getting through a
lot more procedures on a daily basis
than this time last year
and that's going to be helping a lot of
people will it be better by this time
next week better because we'll be
getting through a lot more procedures
okay um let's talk about social care
plan because we're almost out of time uh
we're going to get the white paper i
always think so um the white paper um
later on today um will it be clearer by
then how many people will have to sell
their homes
the white paper that's coming out today
is um
it's less about the the new means
testing system which is really generally
where the detail was didn't we well no
this this white paper i i don't want to
there's a there's a couple of white
papers that are planned for adult social
care and what the white paper today is
about is uh there's in the spending
review there was uh over 5 billion
pounds allocated to adult social care of
that
just under two billion pounds and 1.7
billion pounds is for what's called a a
it's funding for the adult social care
system improvements to the whole system
so this is about spending on the
workforce on on training on
occupational therapy and support people
have to sell their homes well you you
will know today is about how we're going
to support adult social care much more
when it comes to the question you just
asked me about selling homes and not
what we already know you don't have to
wait for that is that we've already set
out plans that means that billions more
a year will be going in to support
people with adult social care costs with
the most generous means testing system
this country has ever seen for adult
social care and with everyone's cost of
care being capped at six thousand we
need another fifteen minutes on that
don't we so i'm sure you'll come back
and talk to us about it in more detail
in the meantime what are you doing for
christmas
i'm spending it with my family in bronze
grove okay just a small group or a big
party just my family there we go it's
good to talk to you thank you very much
indeed it's always a pleasure thank you
and the latest government measures to
combat the new variant dominates most of
the front pages this morning the eye
carries boris johnson's pledge is that
everyone eligible for a coveted booster
vaccine should receive one or certainly
an opportunity to have one by the end of
january and the army are set to be
drafted in to help administer the jabs
that's in the metro the telegraph says
restrictions put into place by the
government today could last until march
of next year they will be reviewed every
three weeks the guardian reports the
prime minister has clashed with his
leading scientist by telling people they
can party
at christmas that was just uh double
down by the health secretary there
wasn't it but he also said have a test
and there's an accusation the government
is sending mixed messages about what it
is and isn't allowed in terms of social
gatherings that's in the star while the
murrah alleges the prime minister and
his staff broke lockdown rules last
christmas by enjoying crowded parties a
number 10 spokesperson has denied the
claims
still to come on the program for you
later this hour we're going to be
speaking to the deputy chief executive
of nhs providers as it warns the
pressure on emergency care is expected
to get worse as winter arrives
tony's law will speak to a boy who had
to have both his legs amputated because
of abuse from his birth parents
also speaking to his adoptive parents
about a new law to punish child abusers
and after eight we'll speak to labour's
shadow health secretary west street
well let's get more now on what the
prime minister is calling another great
british vaccination effort should we
ashna is standing by at a vaccination
center in farnam in surrey for us this
morning hello to you ashna a very good
morning so what's going to happen where
you are
a very good morning kay yeah this
vaccination center opens in a couple of
hours time but it's going to be one of
those that's really going to have to
ramp up it's uh
admit well this distribution of the
vaccine really the health secretary just
then said javid calling this a national
mission a national effort and it really
is going to be a monumental challenge
for so many of these volunteers gps
pharmacists at the moment the nhs is
managing to give out some 2.5 million
jabs per week there's a real ramping up
now to try and make that 3.5 million but
if you look at the statistics that takes
us up to the middle of february but the
moment the government has said they want
to jab or offer up the uh boost
vaccination to every adult over the age
of 18 by january and that is going to be
well a big job for those volunteers as i
say 10 000 of them some 10 000 of them
are going to have to be recruited a real
push there they are going to be paid and
many of them will be working at sites
like this but we know that there is
going to need to be a real distribution
of resources not only have we heard in
the past of a recent past of people not
being able to get through to their gps
not being able to have those
appointments and that's going to mean a
real knock-on effect if resources are
being missed out and being put into
things like this vaccination
drive and coupled with of course the nhs
winter pressures that they're currently
facing there is going to be a huge need
for
lots of senior management uh figures who
are going to have to look at those uh
charts and look at the people and where
they can place them but really this is
going to mean
inevitably in some ways a knock-on
effect on so many thousands even
millions of nhs patients okay ashna
thanks very much indeed thanks a lot so
i forget 23 million people apparently
are going to be slated to have their jab
by the end of january that's what we're
hearing
from the health secretary this morning
but he also said go to your christmas
parties have fun but have a test
before you go remember if you are in
touch with somebody who's had the
omicron variant as we speak you need to
isolate for 10 days
what might that mean for christmas for
you now three students have been killed
and eight others injured in a shooting
at a high school in the u.s state of
michigan police in oakland county say
the 15 year old suspect fired up to 20
shots with a semi-automatic handgun and
was later arrested those killed were two
girls aged 14 and 17 and a boy of 16.
ius correspondent greg milam has more
to that roll call of names in america's
epidemic of gun violence we can now add
the oxford high school a mass shooting
at lunchtime and three teenagers dead
within five minutes of the first
emergency calls a fifteen-year-old
student at the school was in custody but
not before 11 people had been shot and
families had endured the panic and
confusion
i'm just so emotional because
you never think it's gonna happen here
and
the kids just are all a big part of this
community and it is i'm so scared for
them and my daughter is safe but i don't
know if all of her friends are safe and
i don't know if my nieces and nephews
are safe
at the suspected gunman's family home
police searched into the night they say
the pistol used was bought by his father
four days ago as yet they don't know any
motive pictures posted on social media
purport to show the student posing with
the gun
shooting with it and had posted pictures
of a target and the weapon that's all
part of what's being looked at
we're going to do a deep dive
on the social media and all the
activities of this young man
so many communities in america have been
through this michigan's governor
expressing what many feel
this is a uniquely american problem that
we need to address but at this juncture
i think we need to focus on the
community the families supporting all
the first responders including the
incredible people at our hospitals that
are working so hard to save the lives of
of those who are are fighting for their
lives right and i can tell you're so
deep as you should be if you're a mom
and you're a human being you're so
deeply affected by this talk to us about
that
okay this is every parent's worst
nightmare
and once again an american president
forced to offer consolation
my heart goes out to the families
enduring the unimaginable grief of
losing a loved one that whole community
has to be
just in a state of shock right now
police say they're trolling social media
and footage from dozens of security
cameras those who count these things say
this is the 53rd school shooting in
america this year tragically it is
almost certainly not the last greg milam
sky news
and some other stories making news for
you this morning
more than 90 percent of people who lost
powered us due to storm are when have
had their supply restored or being told
but 45 000 are still in the dark five
days on the storm affected power
supplies to around a million homes and
businesses across the country the worst
hit areas are in scotland and the
northeast of england
a three-day strike involving around 50
000 university staff begins today the
dispute relates to pensions pay and
working conditions with further action
threatened if a deal can't be reached
the actions will affect 58 universities
across the uk disrupting teaching for
students in the run-up to the christmas
holidays
experts are warning more than a quarter
of uk birds are seriously threatened the
uk's leading conservation organizations
found swifts and green finches are some
of the species most at risk and are on a
conservation red list it means they're
of highest concern because numbers are
well below historical levels
a new survey for world aids day which is
today has revealed that there is still
stigma and prejudice around hiv four
decades after the disease emerged nearly
90 percent of adults surveyed in britain
were found to have negative perceptions
towards those with the viruses either
bennett reports
there is now a danger that has become a
threat to us all
a lot has changed since this public
health campaign in the 80s when the aim
was to sow fear
if you ignore aids it could be the death
of you
so don't die of ignorance
but that fear in turn created stigma and
prejudice which those living with hiv
still endure today
i heard so many people when they were
told
then when they told their family people
start disinfecting cutlery disinfecting
everything around them
and
the continuous question what do you do
how did you get it like you know you
must be promising school so you must
have done something and that's even now
even yes even now even today
sylvia has been living with hiv since
1997 but she didn't share her diagnosis
for seven years after that
now she leads a charity helping others
with hiv to overcome any sense of shame
and improve their quality of life
we have pills for hiv but we don't have
a pill for stigma stigma can only be
overcome by
you know by information by dialogue by
seeing that somebody living with hiv is
just like you and me it's not it's not
different
according to a new study nearly nine in
ten adults in britain have negative
perceptions towards those living with
hiv
nearly three-quarters don't know that
medication prevents sexual transmission
and staggeringly more than a quarter
wrongly think hiv can be passed on
through kissing
to mark world aids day the government's
unveiled a new action plan to end hiv
infections and deaths by 2030.
scientists say it is achievable thanks
to treatment advances but only if stigma
is tackled too
stigma
prevents people from going coming
forward to have a test
because they're scared of being known to
be positive they're scared of accessing
services and if you don't test then you
can't be diagnosed and you can't have
treatment
high profile figures like former rugby
star gareth thomas coming out as hiv
positive has helped change perceptions
the actor charlie sheen is another
but there's yet to be a high-profile
woman to reveal their diagnosis
which risks hiding another reality that
hiv can affect anyone something sylvia
and others are trying to show
iva bennett sky news
quick look i should say that we're
chatting to david furnish um who's
married to elton john of course um his
uh foundation has done amazing work for
those that are struggling with aids and
also aids awareness out at half past
state quit look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
next few days cold theme returning
showers becoming wintry from the north
rather chilly and windy start with
showers around some heavy and squally in
the south and west expect some
wintriness on the scottish hills as well
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
and some of the other stories that have
caught our eye in the newspapers for you
this morning
this in the mirror one very brave young
man has become one of the youngest
people to ever climb snowden he's only
four his name's alby jr thomas he
skilled the highest mountain in wales
with his dad daniel despite having one
of his legs amputated when he was just
15 months old the pair made the trip in
aid of cancer research let's see if we
can try and get him on the program
tomorrow what a brave little chap he is
also how's this for sustainable fashion
in the times newspaper
that's um
maria
sharapova um she was snapped at the
fashion awards wearing a custom dress
using material made from evie and water
bottles
will it catch on
see things like that things like i
thought of how flexible is it what if
she needs to go to the loo that sort of
thing don't know but it looks pretty
nonetheless and in the express a very
close call on a nature reserve in south
africa where a jeep on safari was
attacked by a six-ton
elephant
he pushed it pushed it off the road
thankfully no one was hurt
besides the vehicle itself but in my
experience
crazed six-ton elephant elephants don't
do that unless they are provoked in some
way or spooked in some way so let's not
be too critical of the elephant daily
express sub-writers this morning thank
you and one-way traffic i think that
might be an understatement on this next
one check this out
england women's football team
last night beat latvia
20
nil in their qualifying match for the
women's world cup
ellen uh white became the team's
all-time leading goal scorer on the
night now leading the way with 48 goals
for her country and it was a
record-breaking night for england too
with the scoreline being the lioness's
biggest ever
win 20
nil that's just showing off isn't it
coming up i'm going to be speaking to
the deputy chief exec of nhs providers
which represents most hospitals in
england as it warns emergency care faces
significant pressure this winter
[Music]
hello again everybody did you hear the
prime minister yesterday he was saying
23 million people will be offered a
booster by the end of next month but in
the meantime you should all have your
christmas parties and everything will be
hunky-dory well the health secretary
sergey javid
we were speaking to him in the last half
hour about the government's measures to
contain the variant mr javid told me
there's no need to change any christmas
plans
um echoing what the prime minister said
but he said well this is what he said
people should continue to behave in the
way that they were planning to behave
over christmas i don't think there's any
need to change those plans the only
changes that have been made in the last
few days are the ones that everyone now
i think knows about about
it might affect your international
travel plan so if someone had plans to
travel over christmas
then there could be an impact there of
course uh there's the need to
self-isolate if you come into contact
with someone uh with uh omicron yeah are
you worried about pingdemk
no no i'm not um the case numbers are
well at this point in time the case
numbers are very low i think throughout
the uk we've got 22 confirmed case at
the moment and that will go up it will
certainly uh go up but the numbers are
low i hope it sort of stays that way so
i i'm not worried about the sort of
pandemic type situation
tamara's here thoughts tomorrow good
morning morning kay well this is again
frantic attempts to dampen down what
jenny harris who's the head of the
health security agency so senior adviser
to the government said yesterday which
is that people should cut down on
unnecessary socializing and that working
from home might be a good idea why are
government ministers going out saying
please don't cancel your christmas plans
go to your parties go to your children's
nativity plays because of course yes in
pure health terms it is correct that if
you don't go to a christmas party or
don't have a nativity play you are less
likely to get covered but the
government's message in the face of
great uncertainty about the omicron
variant is that any moves in that
direction are going to have a big
knock-on effect on the economy
particularly the hospitality industry at
a crucial time for them around christmas
time and they don't want people to
overreact so sajid javid is saying that
the moment the official advice
is that you can carry on your social
life as normal but that he would
personally if he was going to a
christmas party take a lateral flow test
first of course you can't guarantee
everyone else has taken one too but he
says that's a good way of protecting
yourself so the government are saying
look the restrictions are in place are
in or on masks are on compulsory
quarantine and that is as far as they
are going for now we can't say how far
we may need to go in the future in the
meantime they hope to ramp up the
booster program but at the moment only
over 40s can book their boosters yes 18
to 40 year olds will be able to have one
at some point between now and the end of
january but they have not been invited
to book one as yet okay
for now thank you tomorrow's take at
nine o'clock looking forward to it
already thank you uh and of course
hearing from the shadow health secretary
uh in the next half an hour now a new
report has revealed that hundreds of
thousands fewer referrals for suspected
cancer were made by gps in england since
the start of the pandemic
joined now by eve burn from macmillan
cancer support and also craig russell
whose daughter kelly died from bowel
cancer
in june of 2020
hello welcome to you both eve to you
first of all if i may
the pandemic has been challenging for
everybody and none more so than people
who are suffering from cancer give us
some thoughts on that if you would
please leave good morning
good morning well of course this is a
really difficult and worrying time for
people living with cancer we know that
from the report today that between 35
000 and 60 000 fewer people than would
have been expected started their cancer
treatment so we're really worried
because obviously this is causing great
anxiety for people living with cancer
and we're hearing that on our support
line people who are seeing disruption or
delays and are worrying about what that
might mean for their prognosis or or
their experience or their outcomes but
also we're worried because there's a lot
of people out there who haven't come
forward during the pandemic who now will
be coming forward and we're encouraging
them to do so but of course that's going
to create more pressure on the nhs and
we need the government to be taking
action in their plans coming out in the
coming weeks to really address those
pressures
craig your daughter kelly
died
she
had had bowel cancer for about three and
a half years she was in the middle of
chemotherapy during the pandemic what
happened
well she went in for chemotherapy as she
was scheduled to do
went through the blood tests
and at that point she was called in to
see the oncologist who advised her that
the correct course of action at that
time was to stop the chemotherapy
and to self-isolate for 12 weeks
the concern was with
a suppressed immune system that
the
catching covered for kelly could have
been you know extremely serious
so that was the advice that was given uh
but it was something that kelly and the
rest of family certainly didn't agree
with
because the chemotherapy was the only
thing holding the cancer back
and subsequently 12 weeks after she was
told to self-isolate she passed away
my goodness me leaving a little boy
behind as well um eve i'm guessing that
you've heard stories like this time and
again what what can we do to try to stop
the sort of grief that we're seeing the
russell family having to deal with from
happening to others
well this story is just awful and
unfortunately we are hearing many
stories like it at macmillan cancer
support and i would encourage anyone out
there who is worried to get in touch
with us because our support there is for
you
but what we really need at the moment is
the government to be taking the action
to increase capacity in the system it is
not just about increasing uh capacity to
diagnose people with cancer it's also
about
increasing capacity to treat those
people when they do come into the system
we know the government's bringing
forward plans in the coming days and
weeks to address the capacity pressures
and we really need to see cancer be put
front and center to make sure that
people get the treatment and care and
support that they need as soon as they
as soon as they need it
um craig tell us about your your
grandson um he's what he's kelly's son
of course um he's nearly eight is he
he's eight in just a few weeks yes
tell me about him
uh he is a remarkably well adjusted
boy uh considering
not just losing uh his mum but
everything that he went through
during the time that kelly was ill
he is remarkably well adjusted really
he is to a large extent just like any
other seven year old
uh the same mischievous ways uh same
sense of humor
and he has proven to be remarkably
strong in some respects perhaps the
strongest member of the family
what's his name
finley
finley what a lovely name when's his
birthday
just three weeks three weeks to go
oh okay well mine's the 17th is it on
around then maybe we share the same
thing before just because oh okay okay
well i hope that you ha i hope he has as
good a birthday as he possibly can and
christmas is a little brighter for you
um this year as you as you move forward
after the loss of your darling daughter
thank you both for taking the time to
join us this morning thank you
national audit office is warning that
the backlog of nhs care in england could
hit between 7 and 12 million by early
2025 hospitals are warning that urgent
and emergency care is already under
significant pressure and now they face
the looming threat of the new omicron
kovid variant joined now by safran
cordray deputy chief executive of nhs
providers which represents most
hospitals in england good morning to you
saffron i was speaking to the health
secretary a short time ago and he was
saying
could reach 13 million um and we're
really really struggling with call outs
for ambulances where are we going with
all of this
yes well it's it is true to say that the
health service it is under immense
pressure at the moment and you know the
last thing that anyone wanted to hear
was that we have a new variant of of
covid to also grapple with because
trying to deal with that backlog of care
is immensely challenging we've got huge
staff vacancies and we are also looking
as you said at
at the the huge pressure on urgent and
emergency care and other services
including mental health and community
services the thing that we do know is
that the nhs
already has experience in managing these
huge pressures so at the moment we've
got 6 000 patients in hospital with
with covid at the peak of the pandemic
we had 34 000 patients in hospital with
kovid so you know there is there is room
to expand that capacity to deal with
with covid increases but we really hope
that we don't get there so i think it's
it's fair to say that the nhs is is kind
of on standby to expand its its capacity
should it need to do that but it does
come at a cost and that cost will be
potentially cancelling routine
operations longer waits for people who
come into a e for example so we know
that those challenges are there
one aspect that has stretched the limit
of course is in emergency ambulance
calls a million in october that's
staggering numbers some people
dying in ambulances because they can't
get the care that they need waiting for
hours to get into
into a
um do we have to accept that the um the
quality of patient care has deteriorated
for now
i think we have to accept that
the the nhs is under huge pressure and
that does mean that that things won't
happen in the time scales that we want
them to happen and we know that this uh
you know ambulance services in
particular have been under such
huge pressure and there is that real
challenge in terms of handovers between
ambulances arriving at hospitals and
being patients being able to be admitted
that's part of a wider picture and
that's what we have to remember that
this isn't just about the health service
it's also about the health and care
service and we have said for a long time
that what we need to see is some real
changes in the level of support for
social care so that we can make sure
that those who need care in the
community receive it so that they can be
discharged from hospital and help create
that extra capacity in hospital so that
we don't have these blockages that we
see in certain parts of of the system so
it's quite a complex picture when you
start to pull it apart so it's not just
about can't we get ambulances out there
faster well you know the ambulances are
there but unfortunately there is this
this complex chain that needs to take
place in order to admit patients into
hospital and have that capacity so we
know there are huge challenges mainly
those challenges come down to workforce
actually in terms of having the
available staff there to be
patient
almost out of time i wonder if i might
be able to ask you just one for the
question before i let you go and that is
that the prime minister yesterday said
that we should have christmas parties
carry on um as normal um his chief
medical advisor saying no we shouldn't
you shouldn't go to christmas parties
unless um well you just shouldn't go uh
what's your view
well i think this is such a tricky and
challenging issue isn't it because
we've we're at the point this year very
different to last year where where it
was absolutely clear that nobody was
going to a christmas party last year
this year we are in in a slightly
different place people will be taking
their own
decisions we know that many nhs trusts
for example are are asking their staff
not to mix in big groups in the run-up
to christmas because of the potential
threat to their health and and what they
will be available to do so you know they
are they are setting one example there
and i think it at the moment without
that advice from government i think it's
for individuals and individual
organizations to think about what they
will be doing in the run-up to christmas
but you know it's a really challenging
and difficult one and
the thing we can encourage everyone to
do is to go out and get their booster
when it's made available to them and to
book in for that because that's one of
the best defenses that we've got
alongside wearing masks
washing your hands and also making sure
you're in ventilated rooms those are
really really important factors which
will help stop the transmission
okay it's good to talk to you thanks for
your expertise
thank you thank you
still to come the government has backed
new legislation cracking down on child
abusers we're going to be speaking to a
family who've been campaigning for
changes to the law for four years birth
parents did that to that little boy
[Music]
child abusers in england and wales could
face a lifetime behind bars under new
proposals introduced by the government
this week the legislation would raise
maximum penalties for those who harm
children why would you harm a child and
it would mean that for the first time
anyone who causes or allows a child's
death can be hit with life imprisonment
follows a four-year campaign for tony's
law named after tony hutchill who had to
undergo amputation surgery
due to abuse from his birth parents well
it has a happy ending because tony's got
new mum and dad now paula and mark all
three of them are with us now hello to
you all
good morning good morning who's ready
for school there
not me
[Laughter]
tony uh abused as a child as we know i
don't know how much you talk about it in
front of him or what you can say but
paula um mark tell us what you can
um yes so tony came to us as a foster
baby at um
four months old and he was very shut
down withdrawn
um and
very very tiny both his legs were still
in plaster his arms had only come out of
plaster the day before
he'd
suffered multiple fractures and then i
became very very poorly with sepsis
toxic shock and multi-organ failure
um
he's like
just strived along we adopted him he's
at the light of our family um
last year he um did a walk and raised
1.6 million for the evelina children's
hospital on his new prosthetic legs
um and
now he's managed to change the law um
so yeah incredible
there he is dad i think we've chatted
before haven't we um
mark
it's amazing what he's done it's also
amazing that someone that could do that
to him
doesn't get life in prison um up until
now i think we can say in front of him
that um his birth parents were sentenced
to what 10 years in jail you didn't
think that was enough
no i mean they they were sentenced to 10
years in jail and they serve five and
come out next year
um under the new
legislation um that would be 14 years
um but also now they would serve two
thirds of that so it'd be more like 10
years than the five years that that
they've served
you've had a lot of support haven't you
mom um not least i saw some pictures of
him running riot in the um deputy prime
minister's office
yes he literally was running riot um i
think he tried to rewrite dominic rob's
speech as well he was at his computer
um
he's nodding
yeah he we had a great time uh dominic
rob was
very accommodating lovely guy
who said that the government had backed
tony's law which now means that um
like mark said um the maximum sentence
um with tony because he survived was 10
years whereas now that's that's up to 14
years but whereas where if a child died
it was only 14 years that now is up to
life um which is a a massive achievement
um we're we're extremely proud that we
got there
um obviously you know these cases still
need to get to court uh which is
obviously a little bit difficult and
also we're
i think i sort of surprised dominic rob
i
um he asked if there was anything else
he could help me with and i said yes we
need to try
child cruelty register um which he was
surprised actually we didn't have and
unless you sort of think about it you
probably don't realize that there isn't
one you assume there is um but actually
there isn't so these perpetrators can
come out of prison once they've served
their license um they're free to do what
they like so they could actually be
around children have more children
themselves um which obviously is um
ludicrous yeah absolutely
absolutely yeah tony tell me what's your
favorite subject at school
what do you like doing most likely
right
writing when i used to ask my little boy
what his favorite subject at school was
he used to say lunch
so i'm glad that you're saying writing
do you what do you want to do when you
grow up
when you're even bigger
you want to make pizzas
excellent excellent
what's your favorite pizza
pineapple
bit controversial that pineapple on a
pizza but if that's what you like i bet
if you ask your mum and dad for that for
christmas day you'll get it i'm just
saying no pressure on them but i think
that's what might happen
sorry about that mum and dad tony you're
always as you always steal the show
young man thank you so much all of you
for joining us and you've been an
absolute star yeah go on really quickly
we're almost out of time all right okay
um we've set up the tony hudson
foundation if anybody wants to check it
out tony hudgell
foundation.org we're doing a christmas
present appeal and it's to help
other children from
abuse backgrounds
okay fantastic we well you've done it
yourself so i don't need to do that
thanks very much indeed be a good boy
tony and i bet you're fine that father
christmas will come and spoil you this
year do you promise to be a good boy
excellent
look thanksgiving thanks mom and dad
thank you we're back in just a moment
[Music]